principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode to embrace
reality and deal with it the path you
take in life is your most important
decision in my case I wanted my life to
be great and I feared boredom and
mediocrity more than I feared failure
since I didn't start out with money and
I didn't need much more than a bed to
sleep in and food to eat I could skew my
decisions to pursue my adventures so
ever since I was a kid I ran after the
things I wanted crashed got up and ran
again and crashed again and each time I
crashed I learned something got better
and crashed less by doing that over and
over again I learned to love this
process even the crashing part of it
through it I encountered reality and I
learned how to deal with it which
inspired another one of my most
fundamental principles which is that
truth is the essential foundation for
producing good outcomes by truth I don't
mean anything more than the way the
world works I believe that we were given
the laws of reality by nature humans
didn't create them but we can use them
to foster our own evolution and achieve
our goals
realizing that made me a hyperrealist by
which I mean I became someone who has
discovered the great rewards of deeply
understanding accepting and working with
reality as it is and not as I wish it
would be
what I say I'm a hyperrealist people
sometimes think I'm saying that dreams
can't come true that's absolutely not
true without pursuing dreams life is
mundane what I mean is that to me hyper
realism is the best way to choose one's
dreams and then achieve them having big
dreams plus embracing reality plus
having lots of determination will bring
you a successful life I believe this
formula is true for everyone but what
does a successful life look like we each
have to decide for ourselves what
success is I don't care whether you want
to be a master of the universe or to
live under a palm tree or anything else
I really don't each of us chooses goals
based on our values and decides on the
best path to achieve them but we all
need approaches to making decisions that
work well especially when facing
problems mistakes and weaknesses that
stand in our way to succeed we must
embrace all our realities especially the
harsh realities that we wish weren't
true at first looking at these harsh
realities caused me a lot of pain but I
learned that this pain was just
psychological and that my seeing things
differently made all the difference
I came to view problems like puzzles
that would reward me if I could solve
them they would help me deal with the
problem at hand and they would give me
principles for dealing with similar
problems in the future
I learned to treat pain as a cue that a
great learning opportunity is at hand
which led me to realize that pain plus
reflection equals progress meditation
has been invaluable in helping me see
things that way I found that when I
calmed myself down and embraced my
realities and dealt with them the
rewards brought me pleasure and the pain
faded each of us has the unique
capability to think logically to reflect
on ourselves and our circumstances and
to
direct our own personal evolution doing
this well is just a matter of following
a simple five-step process in Episode
three we'll explore what that process is
and how to use it